whenever Morales woke up on Sunday he
was still the president of Bolivia by
midday Tuesday he was out of power and
in exile touching down in Mexico he said
things could have been worse I want to
tell you we're extremely grateful
because the Mexican president has saved
my life
it wasn't easy getting him here the
Mexican Foreign Minister described a
tense standoff before he could work out
a route for him to leave the country but
they were Evo Morales as supporters
surrounding the airport and the armed
forces within it and there was a period
of real tension Evo Morales was already
on board the plane it was the worst
moment president Morales said that a
coup pushed him out on Sunday the army
had asked him to resign he was blameless
he indicated my only crime is that Evo
is indigenous the only sin we've
committed as social programs for the
poor and always searching for equality
and justice if you would deny that you
almost halved extreme poverty and
brought economic prosperity and
stability to the country during his time
in power but his opponents point to a
growing authoritarianism and then
serious irregularities in the last
election he went against the
Constitution to run in the first place
so it's a complex situation here for a
president who over nearly 14 years did -
a lot especially for the poor and
vulnerable in Bolivia before he
disappeared from view he made a call for
peace in his homeland I mean finally I'd
like to say for there not to be any more
bloodshed or more confrontations we've
decided to resign for the people while I
have life we will stand politics while I
have life the fight will continue and
we're sure that the people of the world
have all the right to free themselves
[Music]
that wish is going unanswered in Bolivia
where despite his absence his supporters
and the opposition continued to clash
John Holman al Jazeera Mexico City